Okay, so let's continue from last time.
Uh we discussed how we can minimize the
loss function using the stochastic
gradient descent algorithm. The
algorithm
uh gives updates for the weights or the
parameters of our neural network. So to
recap, given our previous or old
parameters, the algorithm uh updates
them using some learning rate. The
steepest descent of um and or the
fastest way that these parameters can be
updated and give us for give us the next
best parameters. So here we want to zoom
in into this gradient term. Like I said,
this gives us the
uh the direction for the fastest
decrease of our loss function.
And to compute this, we need to compute
how sensitive is L to changing each one
of these parameters.
So here I assumed I have 10 parameters
in total which of course includes the
weights and the bias parameters.
So now the challenge is how to
effectively compute these terms
for potentially
millions of parameters. Calculating this
naively will be very expensive. Here we
introduce back propagation that allows
us to compute this weights very
efficiently. So before going into the
algorithm uh let's recall a basic rule
in calculus the chain rule. So to do
that let's consider with a very simple
case of a single neuron that has an
input u minus one or the activation from
the previous layer that multiplies
with the weight that connects that uh
node to this. This will go through an
activation function and
uh after that that will give us the
value of uh the neuron.
Recall that we had the
bias uh term here that I melted to uh to
be inside this W's. So I'm going to uh
just to simplify my notation I'm going
to melt this into the weight which of
course means that I'm adding a term one
here to this vector. So with that uh
setting aside now we have an input from
the uh activation from the previous
layer multiplied by the weight and then
that goes through an activation
function. Then after that we have the
activation value for the neuron that we
are focusing on. So to simplify the
notation I'm going to introduce
an intermediate
variable here which is basically the
value before the activation. So if I
write it down, it's basically CL is the
value of previous layer multiply by the
weight
and of course like I said the bias. So
the value of my neuron is the value of
ZL going through the activation
function. So now let's assume this is
the value uh of uh the output value of
the neural network and uh we are
comparing this against reference signal
Y and we have a loss function. Let's
assume that loss function is a simple um
quadratic loss and we basically want to
know how we can change the parameters of
this neural network here
in a way that minimizes the loss
function. Right? So we want to compute
the
changes of the loss function with
respect to changes of our parameter here
which is W of L layer L.
So let's write this down in a chain
rule.
So first we have the gradient of L. So
first we are looking at the changes of L
with respect to the changes of the value
of neuron at the layer L
and uh to write the the rest of the the
chain I'm going to write the changes of
the value of L with respect to the value
of this intermediate variable that we
introduced
and then the val the changes of that
intermediate variable with respect to
the changes of W. So basically this
means that if I change the knob if I
have a knob here let's say if I change
the knob for W how much it changes Z
then with the changes in Z how much it
changes A with the changes of A how much
it changes L. So that's how we are
basically changing turning the knob here
for W and then that's how we are
adjusting L and uh in this case our
optimization want to of course reduce L
and this basically give us the gradient.
So at the end of the neural network when
we are computing this loss um this error
is obvious.
So we want to tell the neural network
and we want you to reduce this. So
basically we want to blame the neural
network in a way that the neural network
does something to reduce this blame. So
the blame is obvious. What's the blame
at the end is basically zeror. But it's
not that obvious what is the u amount of
blame for different components of the
neural network. For example, for a deep
neural network, how much of the blame is
uh for a weight at the early stages or
early layers. So basically here what we
are doing is to send or propagate this
error or this blame backward when it's
obvious
to when it's not so obvious. And
basically back propagation is doing
this. it back propagates this error to
the earlier components of the neural
network.
So let's formalize this game of play.
Um
let's start with defining um
intermediate quantity and u this
quantity delta for the layer L. So an
arbitrary layer L is basically the blame
signal for layer L. We define it
basically to be to be this. This means
how much
did the pre-activation value of each
neuron in layer L contribute to the
final loss. So start let's start the
game from the last layer. The last layer
is L. Right? So the blame at that last
layer is written this way. So for a
simple squared error loss. So we can of
course if you remember our notation here
we can write this down using our chain
rule and it will be like this multiply
by the sensitivity of the um activation
function. Right? So when we have vectors
here so this will be a vector
and this will be of course a vector
because we have multiple weights that
goes in uh I'm going to write this uh
element wise um multiplication using
this
um notation which is known as
uh multiplication. So we simplify
because we know everything is vectors
and matrices of course. So let's drop
that arrows. In the case of the simple
squared error loss if you remember this
is basically
this which is literally the the error
right. So this blame at L is the error
and um
scale by the sensitivity of the
activation function um to its input.
Once we know the the blame layer L+1, we
want to back propagate it to the
previous layer layer L. So we have to
multiply this blame by the weights that
are connecting
uh the two
layers which is the weights at layer
L+1. Like I said this is a vector. So uh
we have to take care of this. Uh it's
not a scalar anymore. So, so there is a
a transpose here and of course there we
are uh sending this to the our
activation function.
So what does this equation tell us?
basically tell us that the blame at
layer L is the blame from the next layer
propagated backward through the
transpose of the weight matrix WL + one
and then scaled by the local gradient of
the activation function at layer L. This
allow allows us to move backward through
the network from the last layer to the
previous layer and so on so forth until
the first layer. Okay. So now we have
the blame signal for each layer.
So the gradient for the weights of any
layer L
that we write this way
uh can be found directly using this
layers blame signal and the activation
from the previous layer A L minus one
and it's simply the product of these two
and this basically gives us the update
that is proportional to the blame signal
and the signal that was flowing through
the weights during the forward pass. So
believe it or not, we are really done
here because this uh recursion basically
gives us the update for all the weights
and of course biases.
So that's the elegance of this matrix
vector uh notation. For example, here I
mean I could open this up and write it
this way. Right? This is u uh component
of this vector here is actually the uh
blame signal for a neuron J in layer L.
Right? that we could open this up in
it's really summation form which is the
equivalent form which gives us the
weights uh the sum of the products of
the weights and the
lane from the future
layer right so this is basically a sum
multiplied by the sensitivity of the
loss function so instead of writing this
way, we wrote it this way. It's the
same. So basically this matrix vector
product
um really performs all the necessary
summations that we need. So let's um
even we can look at another example. So
I said that we compute the weight
gradient
and this here is an outer product that
computes the entire gradient matrix in
one step. How does it work? This is
basically
here this is a column vector let's say
of shape m by one. I basically want to
say that if I have a a layer with size
N.
So this is the layer L. If this one has
M neuron, we want to back propagate the
blame from this to the previous one,
right?
And we multiply by uh the blame signal
from L
by the activation
uh vector from the previous layer L
minus one. Uh that is also a column
vector but of shape N by one
and the transpose will be 1 by N. So
this multiplication here gives us a
matrix of m n which is uh basically
matrix with entries like this. So this
resultant m byn matrix is the exact same
dimension as the weight matrix w l.
Right?
So the resultant m byn matrix
has the exact same dimension as the
weight matrix W at that layer. Right? So
an element is basically the plane
from neuron I multiplied by the
activation
from neuron J. So the beauty of this
formulation
is uh not just of course for cleaner
rotation. Um it maps directly to how our
modern harder like our GPUs perform
computation. Matrix multiplications are
highly parallelizable
making this back propagation algorithm
incredibly efficient on a large scale.
This two equation
describe the learning process for a
simple network with a handful of neurons
and also the same equations describe the
learning for a massive foundation model
with billions of parameters.
Like I said, the logic of pro
propagating this blame remains
identical. Only the sizes of the
matrices really change. So let's uh look
at what does this algorithm do. It
basically
u just a g chain rule that compute the
gradients efficiently. It works in two
passes. There is a forward pass that
computes the activations and uh store
the intermediate values. There is a
backward pass that compute gradients by
propagating errors backward. That means
that it computes all the gradients in
one backward pass and it reuses the
intermediate computation
and also of course it exploits the
structure of neural networks.
The error signal delta L
basically summarizes how much each
neuron contributes to the overall loss
and the whole process releasing
uh uh the complexities in O of N. If you
remember N is the number of parameters
of the neural network. So it linearly
scales with the number of parameters.
Okay, so that's it really. we have
everything uh we need. Um so now we can
zoom in into techniques and how we can
do this um training in a way that gives
us the best result for our learning
problem.
So one obvious thing that maybe it's
evident from here is uh the importance
of the activation function right here
this uh sigma prime of CL basically tell
us the sensitivity of this activation
function right how sensitive it is to
the value and the changes of these
values in intermediate layers
In other word, it's like a gate that
control how much gradient is allowed to
flow backward through each neuron. So
the value of this derivative
um somehow determines if the gate is
open, closed or somewhere in between.
And this gating mechanism is critical
for understanding why some activation
functions are preferred over others in
deep networks. For a long time, a common
activation function was a sigmoid
function that basically
uh it squishes all real values into a
range of 01. Uh you can imagine the the
plot and it's fairly easy. It's
basically
a function like this that is between 0
and one. And the important thing here is
the derivative of this function takes
its maximum value uh when it's uh when z
is zero. And this maximum value at z0 is
0.25.
So it's always uh less than that in
other points. And when the input uh is
farther from zero uh to the h direction
it actually the sensitivity becomes
zero. So what does this mean? This means
the sigmoid gate is at best only
partially open and is often nearly
closed. So in a deep network uh these
small derivative
um that are multiplied together each
layer if you remember from the chain
rule
this causes the gradient to shrink
exponentially as it flows backward
a famous problem that is known as
vanishing vanishing gradient.
This makes the the signal the gradient
signal that comes from the uh last layer
to be very weak and it it cannot update
basically the early layer efficiently.
You already know the other option that
we looked at and it's the rectified
linear unit or in short relu. So railway
is basically it takes the maximum of the
signal or zero. It means that whenever
the signal is negative it uh basically
returns zero and when it's positive it
will return the the value of the signal.
This is basically
so what will be the derivative of this
function? We can write it this way.
So notice that I said the derivative is
zero at zero which is not really true
because it's not uh differentiable at
that point. But we really don't care
because the probability of uh falling
the value of Z falling at exactly zero
is almost uh almost zero. So that's why
we just uh correct that uh issue and we
just put zero here. I mean if even if we
had this
if we u push that probability uh to be
one at zero doesn't really matter like I
said because it's very improbable to for
Z to fall exactly at zero. So the
behavior of this uh re gate is very
simple. it's either fully open for value
uh Z that is positive or it's fully
closed. So the consequence is if a
neuron was active during the forward
pass
in other word the value was positive
the gradient pass through it unchanged
during back propagation
uh because of the multiplication by one
right
and this allows the error signal to
travel back through many layers without
diminishing
it acts like a gradient superighway
And um this is a reliable gradient flow
and the reason is primary because of the
relu and other variants of relu that
basically defi is that are mostly
default choice for most deep neural
networks. So let's continue on this uh
conversation.
uh we discussed the importance of this
activation function and its sensitivity
in allowing for the gradients to go
deeper in the neural network. And uh
there are many other uh uh techniques
that help us uh do a better training of
neural network. And uh making sure this
uh forward and backward pass uh will
give us the best result for the specific
data that we are dealing with. and the
amount of information in that data that
we want to pass forward and the amount
of information of the error that we are
receiving from the supervision signal
backward. So this forward and backward
passes we want to make sure that uh we
uh are controlling this uh signals
uh in both ways in a way that we can
reach deeper in the network from both
sides. So for example, one thing that we
really didn't discuss much but we saw
its importance
uh in the stoastic gradient descent
lecture is how to initialize the weight
where to start our search in this
gradient surface
and how to find the uh optimum point
from an initial point. how to set this
initial point in a way that gives us the
best uh basically promise for success.
So, so far we just put an initial weight
to be random, right? So, for example,
some uh very small value scaled by a
random scaling factor, right?
So, this way we uh prevent the weights
from being too large, right? So like I
said a neural network is a pipeline of
sequential computation
uh signal
which in the forward pass is the
activations and in the backward pass are
the gradients.
Uh the signal travel through this
pipeline.
The variance of this signal uh we can
think of it like the energy of it.
It's important to control how it flows
uh in this two direction.
If the variance increases layer by
layer, the signal can grow exponentially
until it becomes uh enormous
uh or in your Python languages uh it
becomes nans.
And this basically leads to exploding
gradients. This exploding gradients uh
renders a useless model.
On the other hand, if the variance
decreases layer by layer, the signal
then shrinks exponentially until it
becomes virtually zero.
Uh this again leads to vanishing
gradients where the early layers of the
network receives no learning signal and
their weights are never updated. So
let's uh think about ways to start this
strategy from a good point. So what is a
good point? Um one measure is we want to
um uh somehow keep the variance of both
the activations and the back propagated
gradients.
So this is a good rule of thumb right we
can at least initialize the the weights
in a way that we ensure the variance at
the beginning is constant. So let's zoom
zoom in into this
to uh analyze the variance of
single neurons pre-activation
value or z. We can basically write it
this way. So Z as you remember is the
sum of
all of these
U inputs X I weighted by uh WIS. So at
the beginning we assume these two are
independent and identically distributed.
It's a reasonable assumption at the
beginning because we haven't done
anything yet. So we choose them in a way
that for example this independence
happen and this pure random will give us
that and then we uh scale the input
input data for example to be uh to have
a mean zero and we can choose the the
initial weight to have mean zero too.
The scaled input data uh can also have
variance zero because that's how we are
dealing with our data prep-process our
data before feeding to the network
and here we want to choose the variance
of W. So now let's look at the variance
of Z given these two choice right. So
the variance of Z can be written this
way like I said because all of this
nice independence
the beginning which basically means that
the variance of Z equals the number of
uh weights or parameters
and variance of W and variance of X. We
know the variance of X is one. And this
basically means that to have a variance
of Z to be one, we it's enough to have a
a weight distribution that has an
variance of 1 N. Right?
So this was for the input when we have
an input with mean zero and V variance
one. And this uh choice of w
ensures that the energy of the input
signal will remain the same uh when it
goes in the forward pass. So so here in
this forward pass by n I mean the number
of inputs to the neuron. Sometimes we
call this n uh subscript n or in other
words on in some circles they call it a
fan in of the layer. So this logic like
I said will ensure the forward pass is
stable. But how about the backward pass?
So if we want to do the same thing for
the backward pass, we want the variance
of w to be one over n out. Right? And
like I said for obvious reason we call
this fan out. So how to make sure we
satisfy these two.
Uh one way to do it which is very common
in the uh activation functions that are
symmetric for example
uh the sigmoid
or um tangent hyperbolic
uh uh we can easily
use the variance of w to be 2 over one u
uh fan in plus fan out. So um that's
great. Um this is known as Javier
initialization
and this is actually very common in uh
training neural network. This is a very
common choice when we have this type of
uh activation functions. But what if we
we don't have a symmetric activation
function and a very common and friendly
example is ReLU. So in this case uh we
only use a fan in for our choice.
So uh notice that this is uh the
variance is half um from the previous
case and the reason is basically ReLU
effectively discards half of the input
distribution because of all the ne
negative values are uh zero and this way
the variance will be half. And then the
other thing is uh we only used um fan in
and the reason is uh because the relu
networks uh are more sensitive to this
value and it's enough to to consider
that. So how we can choose weights to
have uh weight distributions to have
zero mean and this variance one way is
to just use a normal distribution.
Right? So a normal distribution
for weights that follows uh mean zero
and one of these variances right for
example in this case uh we have this
normal distribution.
So to wrap up because ReLU uh activation
functions are very common u it's often
the default choice to go with this and
this is also known as a uh strategy or
initialization
uh strategy.
Um so to summarize um it's very
important to ensure that the energy of
the signal and its variance uh does not
die out or explode as it travels through
the network.
Um you will see that uh PyTorch for
example a modern framework will use uh
this methods when it initialize the
weights of the neural network. And the
difference of doing this or not is the
difference between a smooth or a stock
uh training or an basically a gradient
that flows nicely or vanishes or
explodes and the conversions that can be
fast or slow or even no learning.
So uh we discussed this uh weight
initialization.
It can give us a good starting point uh
point a starting point that is stable.
But as the training progresses the
weight will change. They are constantly
updated and the distribution of each
layer's input can shift and change. Um
this is a a common problem and uh the
issues that we discussed uh including
vanishing and exploding uh exploding
signals uh will and can repeat uh in
this uh process of the training.
Um this is a very common uh issue uh
phenomenon that is known as the internal
coariant shift and the idea is the
distribution of each layer's input
changes during the training and this
complicates the learning of subsequent
layers. Uh there are lots of techniques
uh that are devised to deal with this
issue. uh some uh that are more common
we will discuss in this lecture but of
course there are other techniques that
can be tailored for different
architectures.
So
we will start with a very common
technique that is uh considered
foundational when we are dealing with
the mini batch uh training and the mini
batch is rather not small and it's it
can be reliably large and uh we can use
a batch normalization. So bash
normalization
is basically
u a way to normalize the pre-activation
values in the network.
So it is inserted at
u uh before the linear layers and before
the nonlinear activation functions.
Hence the they are getting the value z.
And how it works is basically for each
mini batch during training batch
normalization first calculates the mean
and variance of these pre-activation
values the Z's and then normalizes them
to have a mean zero and a variance of
one. The normalized Z can be written
this way where mu b is the mean and
sigma 2 uh b is the variance of the
current mini batch b.
So epsilon is a is a constant just for
numerical stability.
Uh this basically gives us um
somehow counterintuitive
uh uh point meaning that we are
introducing new parameters, right? And
why we should force the signal to be a
standard normal
only to immediately change it and the
reason is a standard normal distribution
may not be optimal for the next layer.
So forcing all activations into this
rigid structure might limit the
network's representation power. So how
can we resolve that? To solve this, this
uh batch normalization layer basically
learns two new parameters. A scale
uh that we denote by gamma and a shifted
by beta. So this parameters um gamma and
beta
basically
shift and scale uh the z hat uh that we
uh computed here
and we are going to call it a bash norm
output. So what does this mean?
basically means that the network learns
the ideal mean variance for the
activation. So in the worst case when
the original distribution was best the
network can simply learn the uh to go to
send the C uh hat to the previous point
that it was.
But this uh normalization method helped
for a lot of uh good behavior during the
training. It makes the optimization much
smoother
and the reason is because the last
landscape will be smoother and the
optimizer can converge more reliably. In
that case
the learning rates can be chosen to be
higher which means that the training can
be faster significantly faster in a lot
of cases. And uh on the other hand this
basically has a regularization effect.
The noise the noise that we introduce
with this mini batch statistics
u has some regularization effect and uh
it helps to reduce the need for uh
techniques other techniques that uh does
the same regularization like dropouts
that you will see later also this u
batch normalization um uh even make the
dependence on the initial initial weight
choice even uh less and uh this
basically um
um even if your choice of the
initialization was not the best uh
during the training the batch
normalization will will somehow help to
to fix that uh issue.
So uh even with all of these
normalization techniques
uh as you will see during the course uh
when we train very deep networks this
issue of um vanishing gradients will
eventually uh come at us especially if
we want to go very deep uh training very
deep neural networks. So one way to
resolve that al together is just to add
connections
uh that basically passes the the layers
and this way we basically provide the
the signal from the before the layer to
the after the layer. And uh this way it
it's like not just a highway. It's a
super highway basically. Uh that give us
um uh that allows the input of a block
of layers let's say x here to be added
directly to its output. Um so if fx here
this is the the layer that um acts like
a function fx and then we have the
output here will be
fx
plus x right and uh this basically
is the an inter uninterrupted path for
the gradients especially to flow
through. Even if a particular block of
layer uh like for example here in this
case is not useful the network can
easily learn to make uh its output fx
close to zero right and it's basically
bypass that layer altogether and the
gradient flows backward through the
identity connection uh without any de
diminish in the value.
This uh was the innovation in the
residual network or in short ResNet
architectures
that allows for training very deep
neural networks. One thing that we
should be careful uh when we we want to
use this u technique is to make sure the
output of the layer and the input has
the same shape. Otherwise we cannot use
this uh technique. Another thing is uh
this is designed for very deep neural
networks. So for shallow uh networks
this is not necessary and maybe even not
helpful. So we conclude the lecture
here. Uh but it doesn't mean that there
are not other ways to make sure our
training is not stable. And during the
course you will see that uh we will
choose multiple or combination of these
techniques. And for different
architectures we use different uh
combinations.
And uh these are uh this will be one of
the uh tools in your disposal as a as an
engineer who who does tradeoff for
example in the design which one of this
design for this specific architecture
can give you the best result. And uh
this will be one of the points that you
have to even maybe try different
techniques uh when you are training in
neural network and at the end choose the
one that give you the best soft.